this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
what's up cowboys and cowgirls michael
here and today i want to talk about our
favorite comedic genius turned horror
auteur jordan peele his new movie nope
just hit theaters and while we're gonna
save a full breakdown for its digital
release we're too stoked to wait to
tackle one of the big ideas peel
explores in the film spectacle and we're
not projecting here peel himself said
that the movie is about our addiction to
spectacle and characters in the movie
repeat the word enough just to remind us
nope explores the ways in which we're
all obsessed with spectacles and how we
all secretly hope at least just a little
bit to witness some outrageous moment
that compels us to pull out our iphones
hit record and hopefully find fame even
if doing so is super dangerous so let's
saddle up and see how a sci-fi tinged
horror western can help us understand
our modern condition in this mostly
spoiler-free wisecrack quick take on
nope is everything spectacle now but
before we really get into it i want to
tell you about this video sponsor
surfsharkvpn surfsharkvpn keeps your
data secure everywhere you go on the
internet thanks to their secure
protocols and uncrackable encryption now
one of my favorite things about surf
shark vpn is that it keeps my location
totally private which is a huge help
when it comes to things like buying
plane tickets which is important because
they're really expensive right now
simply connect your secure surf shark
vpn to other vpns around the world and
then you can easily track down the best
deals and speaking of the rest of the
world these connections also let you
watch all the movies and tv you like
especially content that hasn't been
released in your country yet plus all
your favorite devices are included in a
single subscription including your
laptop android amazon firestick
playstation and more and you can still
use your favorite apps too like chrome
and firefox get started by clicking the
link in the description and using the
promo code wisecrack when you do you can
get surfsharkvpn for 83 off plus three
extra months for free go to
surfshark.deals slash wisecrack or hit
the link in the description protect
yourself online and download search
cersvpn today and now back to the show
nope is about a brother oj and sister
emerald whose family farm trains horses
for hollywood productions their great
great great grandfather was the unknown
black jockey featured in the first ever
moving image created by edward muybridge
now while the moving image is real peel
made up the anonymous black jockeys
identity for the film so on-camera
spectacle clearly runs in the family
after their father mysteriously dies oj
notices something strange in the sky
you're probably not stunned that what he
sees looks like an alien spacecraft but
instead of wisely choosing to get the
[__] out and never look back like i
would they decide to try and capture the
sight on camera so they can get there
openshot because why worry about
potentially being zapped or probed to
death by aliens so long as you go viral
and this feels like the first indication
that peel wants us to reflect on our own
societal fascination with spectacle
whether we're creating it filming it or
simply consuming the potentially
horrible and shocking sights from a tiny
screen as we sit on the toilet
none of us seem to be immune okay so in
a surprise twist that would shock even
the most seasoned wisecrack horror fan
we're going to explore this idea with
the help of a french philosopher i bet
you didn't see that one coming but
seriously we can't help it that the
french are good at using philosophy to
analyze the decline of human culture and
one of these folks gee de boer wrote a
book in 1967 called the society of the
spectacle which opens with the line in
societies where modern conditions of
production prevail all of life presents
itself as an immense accumulation of
spectacles for deboer the modern
spectacle has turned a society primarily
based on relations between humans into
one that prioritizes relations between
commodities i.e economic relations
matter more than human beings and we see
a bit of this in an early scene where oj
is treated like by some commercial
director and his real-life horse is
ultimately replaced by a cgi stand-in
according to deboer's definition
spectacle is perceived in three ways all
at once as all of society as part of
society and as instrument of unification
for him spectacle underlies all social
perspectives and all consciousness as he
explains due to the very fact that this
sector is separate it is the common
ground of the deceased gaze and a false
consciousness and the unification it
achieves is nothing but an all-official
language of generalized separation
i.e by keeping us all focused on various
spectacles society turns us into zombies
with deceased gazes isolated from others
and from our own humanity basically
living in the spectacle are constant
impulse to talk about if we've seen the
new thing or heard about what happened
or read the crazy tweets or saw that
weird guy's tick tock or the politicians
leaked nudes becomes what society is for
most of us and in a world where this is
what is most real why wouldn't a brother
and sister in need of cash see capturing
an alien ship on camera as a way to
really make their lives matter when
deboer talks about the unification
achieved by the spectacle being an
official language of generalized
separation he's getting out the way in
which our gaze being caught in the
spectacle alienates us from each other
when our heads are all looking down at
our phones we're not relating to anyone
else and we're definitely not
considering the humanity of those on our
screens and ultimately that dehumanizes
all of us and in nope when the ex-child
star jup hosts the show at his western
theme park we see everyone gazing up at
the spectacle with this deceased gaze
the message seemingly being show me
something shocking or else i'm not
interested and of course here it's being
done for the sake of profit for deboer
the alienation of the spectator to the
prophet of the contemplated object is
expressed in the following way the more
he contemplates the less he lives the
more he accepts recognizing himself in
the dominant images of need the less he
understands his own existence and his
own desires i.e the more we get caught
up in the images and spectacles that are
sold to us the more we lose ourselves in
the process and in nope we see what
happens when individuals get so caught
up in being spectators that they risk
losing themselves in the spectacle now
while we might not be risking our lives
to get shots of extraterrestrials we
might think of the spectacle of the
january 6th attack on the u.s capitol
most of us were glued to our tvs or
phones transfixed by the chaos and if
we're honest there was something sickly
compelling about it that we couldn't
look away from this isn't an individual
moral failure either a lifetime of
constantly consuming spectacle makes
everything seem unreal as the desire to
be shocked eclipses our basic humanity
and of course when you look at footage
from that day it's no coincidence that
so many people have their phones out
recording and streaming the events
because if a right-wing political attack
happens and you don't record it did it
even really happen and at an even darker
level there is a disturbing trend of
mass shooters who are literally
streaming their horrific acts as if they
were just gamers searching for
subscribes and likes with their kills
and nope peel seems to be saying that
the obsession with spectacle is
something that affects all of us and not
in positive ways and as we sit in the
theater transfixed by the screen we
can't help but think about all the
movies we consumed that are themselves a
little more than empty spectacles of
capital as we watch famous actors
phoning in their performances against
cgi backgrounds doing little more than
making empty references and dropping
easter eggs that are more about consumer
desire than they are about engaging
narratives and you know blowing [__] up
they're always they're always blowing
[__] up for deboer the spectacle
presents itself as something enormously
positive and disputable and inaccessible
it says nothing more than that which
appears is good that which is good
appears this attitude which it demands
in principle is passive acceptance which
in fact it already obtained by its
manner of appearing without reply by its
monopoly of appearance so whether it's
our continued consumption of corporately
repackaged ip being served to us across
various screens or people who seem
absolutely unable to do anything other
than put themselves in harm's way to
experience the pure spectacle of chasing
down alien life a society built on
spectacle builds power over us when we
accept the idea that whatever appears is
good and worth watching or as peel puts
it the film also deals with the toxic
nature of attention and the
insidiousness of our human addiction to
spectacle but what do you guys think
does nope persuasively critique our
societal obsession with spectacle or is
jordan peele himself just cashing in on
our love of a good old-fashioned alien
blockbuster let us know what you think
in the comments and as always thanks to
our patrons for your support and be sure
to check out our new patreon features
also if you haven't checked it out yet
check out our new stream wisecrack live
it happens right here every thursday at
11 a.m pacific if you enjoyed our little
spectacle about spectacles be sure to
like this video subscribe and ring that
bell and as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
you